pour protéger ces vecteurs sociaux et
écologiques que sont les forêts il faut
un État fort et présent or la situation
de l'ONF est plutôt le révélateur du
désengagement de l'État en la matière
qui en 20 ans a subi près de 5000
suppression de postes et il semble que
le mouvement soit bien parti pour
perdurer car le gouvernement a décidé
l'an dernier de supprimer 500 emplois
supplémentaires sur 5 ans de fait en
2025 l'ONF cont 8000 fonctionnaires
alors qu'ils étaient 16000 en
1986 derrière ces suppressions de postes
se cache aussi un malaise bien plus
profond et dramatique chez ceux qui par
leur passion entretiennent et protègent
nos forêts entre 2005 et 2020 51 agents
de l'OMF ont mis fin à leur jour ce taux
est deux fois plus élevé que dans le
reste de la population
française ce malaise est un révélateur
de l'état de la profession et ces
suicides ne peuvent s'expliquer par la
seule solitude de Fortier isolé dans les
bois